[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre ce soir
va disparaître l'un des grands mystères
de la vie politique française vous
connaissez évidemment depuis près de 30
ans arlette laguiller elle appartient au
patrimoine politique français elle est
présente à chaque élection
présidentielle en revanche vous ne
connaissez pas le véritable leader de
lutte ouvrière celui que certains
appellent le gourou d'arlette laguiller
aujourd'hui il décide de sortir de
l'ombre certains disent même de la
clandestinité pour la première fois ils
seront côte à côte ce soir ils vont
répondre à toutes les questions que l'on
se pose sur lutte ouvrière et puis ils
seront aussi face à deux socialistes sur
luc mélenchon henri weber et puis à un
autre trotskiste alain krivine
faut-il choisir entre bush et sa dame la
france peut-elle tenir tête aux
etats-unis ces derniers jours le ton a
sérieusement monté entre washington et
paris échanges de petites phrases
cinglantes qui montre et qui illustre
bien le véritable désaccord entre les
deux pays
noda sans aucun doute saddam hussein va
essayé de tricher jusqu'à la dernière
minute
la partie est terminée et star game over
il ya des pays qui sont plus préoccupés
par les états unis que par la lutte
contre le terrorisme les états
terroristes comme l'irak
je pense que l'histoire leur donnera
tort être allié
c'est savoir se consulter
pour trouver un consensus
ça n'est pas de dire
mon idée est forcément la bonne et tous
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec moi
doivent être écartées ou exclue voilà
jacques chirac recevait aujourd'hui
monsieur poutine à paris déclaration
commune russie allemagne france nouvelle
proposition mais sur le fond la position
de la france n'a pas changé
est approuvé par une très large majorité
de français ailleurs c'est toujours un
constat d'échec est la pire des
solutions
il existe encore une alternative à la
guerre on n'a aucune raison de faire la
guerre traqué l'irak et rentrant des les
américains mais je pense que la france a
toujours le choix de sa décision donc en
fait
on n'est pas obligé de suivre ce que
nous disent les états unis vous ça vous
dérange que la france ne suivent pas les
états unis ça me dérangerait
je sais pas mais je pense qu'on a besoin
ils ont besoin de nous aussi sont
toujours été là notre bouche et sa dame
franchement je vois pas la différence et
point économie qui les intéressent en
irak je suppose de pétrole où il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui ils ont un
intérêt quelques par la part peut-être
sûrement pourquoi bouche n'attaque pas
d'autres pays où il ya des dictatures un
plus plus invraisemblables encore voilà
le bras de fer franco américain à propos
de l'irak bien sûr donc la france
peut-elle justement résister à la
pression américaine débat tout à l'heure
entre autres avec alain madelin pierre
lellouche ancien ministre de la défense
alain richard et djamel bouras mais
d'abord revenons sur les mystères de
lutte ouvrière je vous le disais tout à
l'heure bien sûr vous connaissez arlette
laguiller et bien vous allez apprendre
ce soir à connaître robert barcia alias
hardy nathalie saint cricq ludovic
pignolet
travailleuses travailleurs travailleuses
travailleurs
beaucoup disent que je me répète pas été
là j'en suis fier
indémodable arlette sa constance son
éternel discours serait-il la clé de son
succès alors comme on dit dans la pub le
produit l'aiguillé depuis 30 ans c'est
une vraie trouvaille c'est un produit
pourquoi parce que elle a toujours le
même packaging
le même paquet seul mais la même
enveloppe le même logo laguiller c'est
toujours arlette laguiller non c'est
arlette en plus c'est tout le monde
l'appelle arlette on n'a plus pu arlette
laguiller on n'appelle pas son petit nom
ce qui a une conscience apathie énorme
puis c'est une femme c'est une des
premières femmes politiques faut pas
oublier de rendre cet hommage à je suis
une femme et j'ose me présenter comme
candidat à la présidence de cette
république d'hommes est là vous savez
cette petite voix comme ça il sera
ordinaire toujours sur la même fréquence
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'unique parce qu'il faut se
différencier des autres et elle a
surtout ce qui nous intéresse en
politique un discours en un discours un
ton un physique choisi entre tous et
toutes parts hardy lui même pour porter
les couleurs de lutte ouvrière elle en
sera l'unique porte-voix toujours devant
et lui derrière raisons de ce choix il y
avait à lutte ouvrière des militants
ouvriers qui travaillaient en usine
courait plus être tout à fait les porte
parole de lutte ouvrière et qui aurait
véhiculer une image prolétarienne bien
mieux car l'atelier pourquoi qu'il
choisit arles être papa scarlett et des
puces facilement manipulable
manipulable peut-être sympathique pour
beaucoup c'est certain en tout cas le
choix d'arlette c'est celui d'un
trotskisme à visage humain
c'était quelqu'un oui très agréable sur
et qui éveillait qui aimait faire des
tas de choses sortir lire j'aime
personnellement je suis parti en
vacances avec m
bien que j'aimais bien les rapports
d'amitié
sont forcément liés au militantisme
puisque quand on milite à lutte ouvrière
on milite un peu en vase clos on est
entre nous et nos amis sont
militant lutte ouvrière ont fait d'eux
les anniversaires
bon
on faisait des points quand il le
fallait bien sûr on faisait des défaites
entre nous on avait une vie normale mais
entre nous ils vivent en vase clos mais
l'offensive de charme elle est tout
acier 1995 arlette dépassera les 5% un
septennat plus tard ça recommence
pendant la campagne elle a tout d'une
idole fait de l'audience quand elle
passe à la télé sorte d'icône de la
classe ouvrière paris match gala vsd
s'intéresse à elle dans le privé c'est
alors que l'on commence à chercher
l'homme qui se cache derrière la femme
lorsque je pose la question sur hardy
avec la guye et me disais oh mais c'est
un vieux dirigeant à la retraite il est
entièrement retirée on ne le voit plus
parfois on le consulte mais il est
entièrement retirée naturellement basson
son coming-out aujourd'hui montre bien
que elle n'a pas raconté la vérité lutte
ouvrière une organisation opaque et
secrète qui a de plus en plus de mal à
cacher la vérité une machine bien huilée
mais qui parfois se grippe
et j'ai du mal à supporter tout ce qui
se dit autour de ça
je vais me calmer ça va passer je bois
un peu d'eau si on revient l'année sera
formidable mais le début de rupture avec
l'opinion c'est au lendemain du premier
tour quand tout le monde ou presque
extrême gauche comprise se mobilisera
contre le pen en appelant à voter chirac
arlette elle se démarque je n'appelle
pas à voter chirac et je demande à mes
camarades à ceux qui me font confiance
et bien de voter blanc ou nul dans cette
élection elle n'a pas compris que entre
les deux tours il fallait changer de
disque changer de cycle rebondir et
montrer qu'on avait évolué cette marque
ce produit formidable qu'est avec
laguiller pour moi a eu une crise énorme
à ce moment là parce qu'il a coupé le
lien le cordon de sympathie qu'il y
avait entre elle et ses consommateurs
entre elles et l'otan un produit en fin
de cycle s'il ne trouve pas notre cycle
et arbent surproduit meurt
alors arlette en bout de course boudé
par l'opinion démodé isolé il était
temps pour robert barcia alias hardy de
passèrent à la contre attaque et cette
fois au grand jour il devait sortir du
bois pour plusieurs raisons tout ce que
l'on a raconté sur arlette laguiller et
l'ensemble de ce mouvement a conduit à
ce que monsieur hardy disent eh eh bien
il faut maintenant crever l'abcès et
faire de notre faiblesse une force se
montrer au grand jour et faire tomber
ainsi les préventions car ce que ce dont
il s'agit fondamentalement ce n'est ni
de la gauche ni la droite ni des
réponses aux problèmes auxquels la
gauche populaire est confronté c'est une
compétition entre monsieur besancenot et
arlette laguiller lutte ouvrière entre
la sarl tout rires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
ça va voilà alors merci à vous et à
l'aide d'aiguillés d'être là et puis à
vous aussi bien sûr robert barcia alors
vous publiez donc ce livre la véritable
histoire de lutte ouvrière à des
entretiens avec christophe bourseiller
d'abord alors vous présente toujours
comme l'inventeur avec des guillemets
bien sûr d'arlette laguiller est ce que
ça vous fait plaisir ou est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est un peu réducteur car
c'est une ânerie pourquoi c'est une
ânerie parce que je n'ai pas inventé
arlette l'aiguillé elle était c'est amer
qui l'inventé pas moi il a fait un qui
est la fête mais qu'il a inventés ou
sylvain sa mère et son père c'est vous
qui l'avez choisi quand même non c'est
pas moi nous l'avons choisi
collectivement et même elle s'est
imposée à nous parce que elle était une
militante du crédit lyonnais elle était
une militante syndicale elle avait un
passé politique qui n'était pas avoir
ouvrière ou à lutte ouvrière elle avait
un passé politique au psu elle avait une
formation politique c'était une
travailleuse elle n'avait pas de diplôme
elle était intelligente et l'unanimité
de ceux qui ont décidé c'est à dire d'un
grand nombre de camarades ont choisir
d'être laguiller d'abord dans les
élections législatives pas à la
présidentielle parce qu'il ya eu des
effets plutôt qu'un oui et tout le monde
a été enchanté du choix et c'est tout
naturellement que tous les camarades se
sont dits va c'est arlette pour les
présidentielles et vous êtes un très bon
coup parce qu'on le voit bien c'était
une femme elle était jeune c'était la
première fois qu'il y avait une femme
candidate à l'élection présidentielle
franchement vous avez un bon sens de la
communication
non on vend pas une candidate et surtout
une femme comme une marque de lessive
votre conseiller en communication là
c'est un imbécile c'est un escroc un
mois je voudrais pas et devait avoir de
la lessive à vendre par ce mec là aussi
en communication et lutte ouvrière sera
compris un le nombre je sais pas avec
qui travaillent mais écoutez on vend pas
une femme ce commun comme une lessive
comme une marque de lessive comme des
chaussons comme c'est pas vrai ça il
faut être misogyne absolument comme on
pourrait croire que ça n'existe plus de
nos jours quand même après mai 68 pour
oser dire des choses pareilles un qantas
être là lui sont annoncés çà vous aimez
pas les anciens du tout si on aime les
anciens du tout vrillière et vous n'avez
pas choisi pour répondre parce qu'elle
était comme il le dit plus malléable que
d'autres celui qui dit ça oui
l epa malléable maintenant on n'est pas
malléable vous l'avez vu dans des
interviews vous l'avez vu faire face à
un maigret vous l'avez vu faire jeter
pas là 1 vous l'avez vous êtes est
malléable mais non on n'est pas
malléable nous l'avons choisi parce que
tu étais une femme une militante une
femme de tête une femme qui tenait tête
aux patrons au crédit lyonnais une femme
qu'ils étaient des milliers temps de
syndicalistes voilà pourquoi nous
l'avons choisi entre autres alors vous
l'avez beaucoup médiatisé on l'a vu au
fil des années c'est vous qui l'avez
médiatisé mais les obligés d'accepter
des choses qu'elle refusait avait quand
même par exemple on a vu gala paris
match on s'est dit c'est bizarre quand
même s'employer bras arbitre c'est moi
qui décide si j'accepte telle ou telle
interview pas quand j'ai pas de doute je
décide quand j'ai des doutes je consulte
mes camarades a redit comme les autres
de la direction d'uts ouvrière en dix
ans on propose ça ça me paraît pas
terrible qu'est ce que vous en pensez et
ont discuté des camarades disent cette
émission je la connais pas d'autres
disent pas si c'est pas mal j'ai écouté
on discute c'est tout mais quand même
j'ai droit à la décision en plus je fais
partie de la direction de lutte ouvrière
depuis 1970 donc j'ai participé à toutes
ces décisions me concernant je pouvais
dire oui je pouvais dire non je peux
accepter ou pas accepté alors on verra
si on se demande pourquoi vous avez
décidé aujourd'hui de parler c'est
pourquoi parce que arlette laguiller a
été dure et plus il ya longtemps je veux
dire on part de vous on vous cherche
vous dites même on vous tracts on a
écrit des calomnies selon vous c'est ce
que vous avez dit depuis au moins je
sais pas disons allait presque une
dizaine 5 680
2018 alors pourquoi en 98 voyant qu'ils
avaient perdue papier sur vous on disait
mais qui est la grande presse a écrit
vous n'aurez jamais raison contre un
journaliste il vaut mieux méprisés alors
c'est ce que j'ai fait là aujourd'hui si
je prends la parole c'est pas pour me
justifier c'est pas pour justifier lutte
ouvrière c'est pas pour justifier nos
attitudes ou arlette laguiller ou le
choix d'arnaud c'est pour raconter
l'histoire de lutte ouvrière pas ce
qu'on écrit des tas de choses sur
l'histoire de lutte ouvrière tout aussi
tous plus force les unes que les autres
alors j'ai 75 ans ou presque il est
temps pour moi d'écrire cette histoire
que plus personne d'autre ne pourrait
écrire après moi puisque après la mort
de pierre bois qui était lui le leader
historique de lutte ouvrière auquel
personne s'intéresse elle soit d entre
nous son nom était connu il était dans
l'annuaire mais y'a pas un journaliste
qu'elle est gay l'interviewer le jour de
sa mort alors là il fallait absolument
qu'on aille visiter sa dépouille pas
nous ça c'est des charognards et c'est
pas des journalistes ont pour mère
pourquoi en 98 justement quand tu as eu
des tas de questions autour de vous vous
n'êtes pas dit ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui je vais raconter l'histoire
du tout vrillière je vais raconter ma
vie à moi qui comme ça on va arrêter du
d'hier des choses qui me plaisent pas
sûr lutte ouvrière écoutez j'ai répondu
au monde
une grande réponse un droit de réponse
ça n'a rien arrêté il y avait tout là
dedans dans ce temps ma réponse y avait
déjà tout bon ça n'a rien arrêté
pourquoi continuer et puis en plus on
entrait dans des périodes électorales on
entrait dans des périodes électorales
avec des calomnies avec des médisances
avec un enjeu bien c'était arlette
laguiller qui était de porte parole elle
est restée notre porte parole dans
durant toute cette période
maintenant nous sommes sortis d'une
période électorale je sors mon livre je
sors mon histoire de lutte ouvrière je
sorte l'histoire de lutte ouvrière pas
mon histoire et vous sortez aussi de la
clandestinité parce que votre histoire
c'est aussi celui qui est celle de
quelqu'un qui entre dans la résistance à
l'âge de 15 ans et puis la résistance
après vous glissez bon vous choisissez
effectivement les trotskistes contre le
communisme et puis vous êtes en quelque
sorte un temps je vous signale que c'est
pareil c'est pas l'autre ce qui se meut
contre le communautaire le pc alors je
vais dire contre des biens contre le
stalinisme alors vous êtes au fond
restait clandestins depuis l'année 1943
c'est la clandestinité sa mode de vie
mais non pas du tout les premières
publications veut parmi les premières
publications qu'on a eue c'était mon nom
et mon adresse qui était dessus c'est
comme ça que hier franck est venu me
voir bon ensuite j'ai pas du tout été
qu'un destin la première photo de moi
qu'on a publié dans l'express en 98 elle
avait été prise un enterrement de
de pierre man 2 mais ce modèle bon
j'étais donc assez est entièrement en
vue et au vu de tout ce qu'on vous a
raté on n'a pas été bon sur sur les
journalistes ont pas été bon pas su bien
l'enquêté si il ya un journaliste qui
m'a pris en photo et puis que qu'il a
publiés dans l'express donc je ne me
cachais pas donc qu'il pouvait connaître
c'est pas eu photo c'est pas une
identité il pouvait connaître mon
identité d'après cette photo il l'a
trouvé bon facilement sa tête n'a pas
été une enquête terrible mais d'autres
obsèques j'y suis allé aussi jeté aux
hawks pour ne parler que d'obsèques jeté
au sol et ça qu'ils obsèques quand même
on aurait pu voir peut-être ailleurs à
la salle et ouvrir tous les ans ou tous
les ans la fête de lutte ouvrière je me
promène dans les allées devant des
dizaines de milliers de personnes je
m'assois à table pour manger des
sardines ou pour changer quoi que ce
soit narrativement décidé mais non par
exemple pourquoi vous n'êtes jamais
baladé tous les ronds vous voit pour la
première fois tout ça on vous arrête
de nous avons tous les débats vont
chercher les relais on n'intéressait pas
c'est tout on a intéressé à partir du
moment de 98 tout un journaliste a
prétendu que j'étais un grand patron de
l'industrie pharmaceutique alors
j'annonce que la question aussi c'est
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pendant
toutes ces années alors ça vous énerve
aussi quand on dit que vous avez fait du
business au fond que vous avez été un
business man c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai j'ai été licencié
aujourd'hui à chaque fois qu'on licencie
qu' un plan de licenciement on donne un
petit pécule aux ouvriers des censiés en
leur disant tiens vous allez montez
votre entreprise 1
encore assez malheureux de metaleurop
c'est ce qu'ont ordi et ben moi j'étais
foutu à la porte aussi avec un petit
pécule et qu'est ce que j'ai fait et ba
j'ai monté ma petite boîte et c'est
resté une petite boîte est gelée pas
agrandi j'ai pas voulu d'un grandir
parce qu'il aurait fallu que je
travaille beaucoup pour l'agrandir et
j'avais je refoulais consacré toute mon
énergie à militer alors ça c'est aussi
ce que vous demandez à tout le monde
c'est à dire et je pose la question elle
était gay quand on a entre à lutte
ouvrière c'est un sacerdoce qua non non
je n'en savais que ce camarade là qui
dit qu'on vit entre nous c'est pas vrai
elle vit entre nous parce que c'est une
camarade du crédit lyonnais et au crédit
glamour des nombreux
paradis sont dans la vie de nos
camarades d'entreprises qui sont dans la
vie ils sont avec leurs camarades de
travail sont pas avec des militants lui
ont dit certains membres de lutte
ouvrière quand on est dans une
entreprise généralement nous ont dit on
adhère un syndicat on est estampillé le
tout vrillière on a le droit de dire je
suis membre de l eau ou pour des raisons
de sécurité ou de prestations vous dites
il vaut mieux dire et on vit quand même
le militant lutte ouvrière qu'il affirme
qu'il est d'ouvrières qu'il affiche ou
qu'ils n'affichent pas et vit quand même
dans le monde dans le milieu dans la
classe ouvrière s'il est ouvrier dans
dans le milieu social où il est dans
enseignants s'il est enseignant bon
alors certains peuvent le dire nous
avons cinq mille camarades qui sont
présentés aux élections municipales
bon c'est pas très bien vous avez cinq
militants sa légère plus que ça puisque
ça bah oui parce que nous n'avons pas
confidentiel mais non nous n'avons pas
pu nous présenter militants de
sympathisants nous n'avons pas pu
présenter des listes partout il faut
parfois 50 60 70 personnes qui habitent
la commune pour pouvoir se présenter aux
élections municipales
nous n'avions pas toujours soit 50 60 70
candidats à présenter et nous avons
quand même parfois une dizaine ou deux
dizaines de camarades dans une ville en
janvier l'engagement personnel vous
aviez dit vous avez dit c'est un peu
chez un peu comme soeur emmanuelle ben
c'est pas du racisme non je dirige mais
l'engagement fausse fois plus cher à ses
juges mais j'en retire c'est bien s'est
allongée non sans passion les tournées
insurgés parce qu'on me rapproche
presque de ne pas avoir fait d'enfants
d'avoir fait le choix ne pas avoir
d'enfant et je dis bon il ya des gens
qui se dévouent des religieuses qui se
dévouent pour des causes et on leur
reproche pas ça pourquoi moi qui suis
athée laïque on me reproche que pour
construire un parti révolutionnaire ce
qui est pas une chose si facile et
j'essaye depuis des dizaines d'années on
me reproche avait fait le choix de ne
pas avoir d'enfant voilà c'est la seule
comparaison que j'ai fait mais c'est
quand même un engagement sont % ou est
ce que c'est vrai qu'on conseille quand
même à lutte ouvrière de s'engager dans
des professions qui permettent de donner
un peu de temps de militer le plus
possible c'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai ça
dépend comme ça c'est pas vrai c'est à
dire qu'on commande dire donc ce soit
vrai ah bah oui justement faut le dire
dans le bon sens c'est dire c'est les
gens qui choisissent c'est à dire que
s'ils sont comme moi qu'ils ont envie de
militer militer à plat bah ils se
débrouillent pour exercer une profession
où il gagne d'un tout petit peu leur vie
oui ils ont pas de patrons par exemple
moi c'était mon cas c'est pour ça que
j'ai monté ma petite boîte j'avais pas
de patron j'avais pas de comptes à
rendre bon quand je claquais du bec et
ben je travaille un peu plus quand ça
allait mieux qu'ils avaient des rentrées
bon bah je pouvais me lisez un peu plus
bon voilà c'est tout simple alors nous
avons des camarades qui sont enseignants
disposent de plus de temps que quand on
est sur scène aaron ou à 6 3l bon et
nous leur conseillons d'être enseignant
nous conseillons nos camarades de
poursuivre leurs études avant nos
camarades étudiants de poursuivre leurs
études le plus loin possible
bien plus loin possible
en plus ils vont loin plus et peuvent
gagner correctement leur vie en
travaillant moins c'est malheureusement
comme ça
c'est tout mais nous ne disons pas
vendre des carottes sur le marché pour
pouvoir avoir du temps pour pour me
livrer vous gérez vous ces martiens ou
pas murray des hommes mariés non vous
êtes contre hommage vous rappeler sa
sélection principe de retrait je suis
pour l'union livres pour l'union nîmes
construit match mais en tant
qu'institution d'autres tentes ont des
comptes en tant qu'institution oui je
suis pour l'union libre depuis 68 on a
le droit quand même que savez il ya eu
de la libération sexuelle je
suis crevée ramon pas que je suis contre
le mariage mais les gens qui veulent se
marier je suis juge au contraire et les
gens qu'on empêche de se marier sous
protêt ce qu' ils n'ont pas les
pratiques sexuelles de tout tout un
chacun et de nos députés je suis pour
qu'ils aient ce droit est ce que on a
dit qu'on s'amusait pas beaucoup à lutte
ouvrière quand une vie austère quand on
part en vacances ensemble il faut faire
très attention en ce sens on ne partait
pas on va que vous partez ce parler des
militants d'ouvrières
on aggrave partie avec des non militants
du tout bien sûr bien sûr et il ya
énormément de couple dans la lutte
ouvrière ou l'un militer pour l'autre et
partent quand même en vacances ensemble
on leur interdit pas de partir en
vacances ensemble
tout ça c'est des âneries que certains
bon je veux pas parler tout le temps du
mal du journalisme enfin j'en ai
beaucoup quand même vous en dites ah si
vous aviez parlé plutôt que catherine
journaliste aurait dit non mais non
c'est pour des raisons politiques que
nous attaquent vous comprenez moi je
suis un communiste je suis communiste
depuis 60 ans communiste simple pour le
moment sa mauvaise mauvaise ambiance oui
je suis communiste oui et je le défends
et je le revendique
et oui j'ai des idées qui sont les idées
communistes c'est à dire l'union libre
c'étaient les idées communistes et même
les idées des socialistes et même des
radicaux socialistes vous n'avez pas
connu vous êtes trop jeune mais les
radicaux-socialistes
d'avant guerre edouard herriot le maire
de lyon radical socialiste il était pour
l'union libre il n'était pas marié bon
et puis à l'arrêt d'autres comme lui
énormément ben ça s'est perdu à évoluer
maintenant on est haut il faut être bien
pensants lama je suis pas devenu bien
pensants on s'est tous alors quand vous
parlez j'ai une sexualité qui peut
entrer dans les détails les salaires
vont baisser votre sexualité normale ou
pas cela dit vous vous disiez je suis
communiste bon différence aujourd'hui
ceux qui vous écoutent de 10 différence
alors on va pas refaire l'histoire du
trotskisme on met pas beau pas les
relations pas très bonne vous disiez
évidemment très mauvaise avec la liste
est ligne 1 est mauvaise toujours avec
vous les considérez comme sa ligne à
ceux qui dirigent de pc aujourd'hui non
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
les staliniens
au temps des procès de moscou attendait
des procès des médecins en blouse
blanche autant de lait là les traces
mans par les chars russes de
l'insurrection de budapest
autant de du coup de prague bon ben moi
j'étais contre et c'était antistalinien
alors que beaucoup d'intellectuels
d'aujourd'hui qui sont là ou ailleurs
eux ils étaient déjà il était là-bas et
puis maintenant ils sont du côté des
partis bourgeois bon bah pour moi pas
moi et puis que voulez vous je suis la
punaise dans leurs godasses le
probablement est bon il n'aime pas les
gens comme moi je suis un dinosaure
peut-être comme dirait mon ami alain
krivine oui mais il va venir on peut
aussi commander un dinosaure c'est vrai
que ce qui nous étonne c'est que je dis
à jean viard clandestinité entre
guillemets de même si vous connaissez un
peu ce mot on vous apparaissez regardez
vous avez vu les vêtements voix sur un
plateau de télévision pour la première
fois moi j'aurais bien aimé vous invitez
depuis longtemps oui de nos réseaux
fermés lundi d'accord c'est pas la
clandestine bouche petit pas vous
montrer au grand jour nice mulhouse et
c'était quand tu étais jeune christophe
collègue m'a dit mais vos camarades se
réunissent dans les arrière salles de
café comme sous l'occupation ou faudrait
quand même pas la pauvre 1
sous l'occupation les résistances
réunissait pas dans les arrière salles
de café et aujourd'hui si nos camarades
se réunissent dans certains camarades se
réunissent dans des arrière salles de
café c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens de se réunir ailleurs bon point
mais c'est pas de grande instance alors
non mais enfin vous ne souhaitiez pas
apparaître au grand jour vous êtes
toujours plus de nîmes un art dit ça
c'est il ya toujours un côté parce que
j'aime bien ce pseudonyme alors que je
le parle de toi mais pour claude baillet
200 cars bondés compte depuis quoi 50
ans vous promener avec seul chu de nîmes
darby et alors et pourquoi rld idée me
retiens
ça c'est toute une histoire mais enfin
c'est pas ça n'intéresse pas si c'est
laurel et hardy c'est ça ouais réponse
que j'avais un peu d'humour alors hein
ce qui prouve que vous avez un peu
d'humour vous en doutez une les mains se
poserait question et bien je vais
écouter quand je suis sorti de prison
devait rencontrer le groupe bart afin si
vous lisez pas si vous lisez mon bouquin
bas vous saurez un peu ce que ça veut
dire
il fallait que je prenne un pseudonyme
parce que c'était encore l'occupation
alors je dis aux pc je m'appelais bob
alors comme mon prénom et robert les
camarades ont rigolé non c'est quand
même un peu trop transparent bond vers
le sébum aussi mais c'est beaucoup plus
tard oui oui et alors je me suis
retrouvé à choisir un pseudonyme et
j'avais un camarade qui me quittait pas
on était tout le temps ensemble et lui
étaient gros alors que j'étais
extrêmement maigre alors on a pensé tout
de suite à leur et leur nid mais comme
m'appeler lors elle est appelée lui a
redit c'était un peu trop doux désigné
on intervertit voilà tout alors un petit
un petit mot quand même si vous prenez
est ce que vous pensez de choses
pouvaient prendre le pouvoir en france
demain oui non ou est-ce que ça ça reste
sur un taux qui devrait vous rêvez
toujours du grand soir ou pas cela non
attendez madame
j'ai pas choisi les bons non vous n'avez
pas choisi les bons bon c'est pas moi
qui prendrai le pouvoir c'est la
majorité de la population
sinon ça nous intéresse pas nous nous
sommes pour une société démocratique
c'est à dire une société où c'est pas un
parti une minorité qui prend le pouvoir
c'est la marge heures était par contre
ce que nous voulons c'est qu'aujourd'hui
par exemple
là on est sur une chaîne publique mais
des trois quarts les quatre cinquième
des neuf dixièmes de la presse
appartiennent à des grands groupes
financiers l'édition appartient des
grands groupes financiers aujourd'hui
les gens de metaleurop se font foot à la
porte comme des malpropres et les à
leurs anciens patrons veulent même pas
d'évoluer et l'état dit le gouvernement
dira c'est des patrons brigands mais on
n'y peux rien la loi y peut rien des
traces de pétrole y et polluent les
côtes de pratiquement des côtes du nord
jusqu'à
jusqu'à l'espagne et on n'y peut rien eh
bien oui des grands groupes pdc ces gens
là t'as pouvoir considérable quand on
proteste ils disent bon va dès que le
délocaliser
augmenté nous de nous donner d'une chute
de dénoue des subventions mention 1 et
sinon on délocalise bon ils prennent les
subventions d'ailleurs aidé de la calice
quand même bon eh bien ces gens là ils
ont un pouvoir économique un pouvoir
social et bien ce pouvoir social c'est
une véritable dictature c'est la
dictature de la bourgeoisie alors c'est
ce pouvoir l'anac nous voulons leur ôter
c'est à dire en leur ôtant de ces moyens
de pression sur la société et pour le
reste nous voulons une société
démocratique
pour l'ensemble de la population
c'est-à-dire des conseils des comités de
ce que vous voudrez des parlements un à
l'échelle nationale à l'échelle
régionale à l'échelle locale et qui
roulait où les élus soient révocable des
élections révoqua par les claviers vous
avez aussi un pseudonyme on dit que
c'est bizet c'est vrai oui c'est ça mais
pourquoi est ce que vous aimez chanter
ouais j'aime bien le père abl vous aimez
chanter alors on va montrer non je sais
pas chanter l'opéra non pas sur le
regard que vous chantez quand même sous
des tentes alors on vous a vu beaucoup
beaucoup ayant beaucoup d'occasions on
va écouter ce petit moment des chansons
t'en fais pas
mon p'tit loup
c'est l'avis ne pleut pas oubliera mon
p'tit loup
ne pleure pas
je t'emmènerai sécher tes là
vends des quatre wild-cards dit
ce minerai
violette d'or et les épices à colombes
on verra le
[Musique]
les orchidées
et les enfants qui se savent
m
le coupé
mondou
ne
tu oublies
nous on me dit qu'on n'est pas gay mais
vous n'êtes pas y est c'est pour ça oui
quand même
vraiment je chanson gaie mais non mon
p'tit loup c'est pas la manière dont
vous appelez effectivement j'imagine
robert barcia vous avez pour lui quoi 2
de l'iss tim de la révérence
d'admiration c'est votre modeste et on
anime je pars en deux jours
qu'est ce qui représente pour vous bah
oui à la fois une immense estime une
immense fraternité et puis aussi toute
une expérience qu'il a pu nous
transmettre
d'une époque différente de celle dans
laquelle j'ai milité et qui est
extrêmement importante pour la formation
d'un militant je crois qu'on peut pas
faire de politique dans une période hic
si on connaît pas ce qui s'est passé
avant comment les communistes
révolutionnaires les trotskistes ont pu
intervenir à cette époque et c'est donc
tout y représente toute cette filiation
et puis des combats communs depuis des
dizaines d'années maintenant voilà c'est
vrai que vous ne faites rien parce qu'on
va en paille dans un instant on dit que
c'est un autocrate que vous ne pouvez
rien décidé que rien ne se décide à une
ouvrière sans son avis essentiel c'est
une blague nous nous avons une direction
qui est élu tous les ans un comité
central je me demande si on n'est pas le
seul parti qui tous les ans
si c'était ça le tour hier on l'a pas
ouvert jusqu'à présent alors est ce ça
fait vraiment presse ça c'est pour
l'instant on n'a pas l'intention non
mais vous savez nous on a beaucoup
d'ouvriers d'employés à lutte ouvrière
notre congrès y dure en gros un jour
deux demi journées
non c'est pas ça c'est qu'on peut pas
faire le cinéma d autres qui vous invite
à une petite partie puis qui font tout
le reste à huit clos mais au moins ce
congrès au delà des délégués il ya des
centaines de militants que s'ils ont
envie d'y venir qu'ils peuvent y venir
assister à l'élection du comité central
par les délégués à l'élection du comité
exécutif et c'est cette direction qui
ensuite décide pendant toute une année
non seulement de la politique qui a été
décidé au congrès mais de toutes les
choses qui a à faire quotidiennement
alors vont nous rejoindre je vais dire
qu'on fait une petite réunion de famille
ce soir puisque on vous a vu pour la
première fois l'un et l'autre on va
être vous allez être rejoint d'abord par
alain krivine qui est toujours
responsable j'allais dire c'est la
maison d'à côté là une cr oui j'ai des
cousins
masquer votre joie la bombe
alors à vos origines communes cesse les
listes que sont jean luc mélenchon et
henri weber l'un appartenait aussi à une
organisation trotskyste dans sa jeunesse
henri weber est venue de la lcr et puis
thierry jonquet qui est écrivain et qui
lui a passé quelque temps à lutte
ouvrière alors pour ça veut dire un
petit peu
sur les quelques questions que se posent
encore au fond sur les mystères biens
furent les questions de lutte ouvrière
puisque depuis le temps qu'on en parle
tout n'est pas très clair emilie jeanson
valérie lucas
[Musique]
si l'on se presse c'est pour l'avoir car
lutte ouvrière aux yeux de tous c'est
elle arlette laguiller l'unique porte
parole de l'organisation trotskiste
depuis 30 ans pourtant elle n'en est que
la vitrine
l'homme qui tire les ficelles dans
l'ombre depuis 42 ans le voici
robert barcia pseudo hardy numéro 1 de
lutte ouvrière inconnu du grand public
approché par les seuls militants de
confiance dans sa vie professionnelle il
est chef d'entreprise au service de la
très capitaliste industrie
pharmaceutique
daniel bolloré l'a côtoyé dans son
métier elle est tombée des nues en
découvrant sa double vie un grand choc
un grand show et je lui ai dit mais
c'est vrai ça m'a fait un très bon choix
c'était pas du tout quelque chose qu'on
pouvait soupçonner pas un instant il
travaillé pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique c'est à dire qu'ils
formaient des visiteurs médicaux ils
avaient une école de formation de visite
médicale il a toujours je présume enfin
la société
il travaillait pas il faut dire que
toute l'industrie pharmaceutique a
travaillé à travers lui bernard s'être
lui aussi a bien connu robert barcia
entrée à lutte ouvrière en 68 il en est
parti en 1989 aujourd'hui le regard est
critique pour lui barcia entretien le
culte du secret pour éviter la
contestation
il dit nous ne sommes pas une
organisation clandestine évidemment non
parce que les militants sont connus 1
mais nous avons un mode de
fonctionnement conspiratif c'est à dire
avec des règles de sécurité par exemple
bien évidemment les ce donington en a
parlé mais ça c'est très fréquent mais
par le fait d'aller chez les militants
les mythes en nous parlant d'elle les
gens sur les autres sauf pour une
réunion mais si vous allez par exemple
le mercredi soir chez un militant pour
une réunion de cellule vous avez pas le
droit d'y aller un autre soir simplement
pour boire un coup avec lui ou lui
parler parce que hormis j'ai parlé au
regard d'une cassette télé ou quoi que
ce soit en fait si oui il est impossible
pour les militants de se rencontrer de
se faire une opinion commune qui soit
différente de celle qui est tombée du
sommet c'est à dire de a redit qu est le
seul et l'unique dirigeant en attendant
de changer le monde lutte ouvrière exige
de ses militants d'autres sacrifices on
demande aux militants d'arrêter leurs
études de vivre de petits boulots
alimentaires de ne pas avoir d'enfants
ce qui fait qu'au bout d'un certain
temps ça devient un mode de vie
particulier différent de celui du reste
de la société et que son mode de vie on
peu différent heures peut difficilement
rompre avec
autant de particularisme que lutte
ouvrière n'a même pas voir s'étaler dans
la presse françois koch est devenu leur
bête noire pour avoir publié la première
photo de robert barcia il y a cinq ans
lorsqu'on demande à voir
un autre dirigeant que avec la guye et
les otites mal vu on nous accuse d'être
fou hummer de ce qui pour eux est aussi
insultant que l'orlistat d'investigation
il y avait une technique qui est
d'ailleurs tout à fait similaire
technique des sectes qui pour intimider
et museler la presse multiplie les
procédures judiciaires
si avec l'apparition publique de robert
barcia l eau est peut-être entrer dans
une nouvelle ère d'autres pratiques
moins transparents persiste pour leur
lutte ouvrière n'a toujours pas de siège
social mais une simple boîte postale
alors vous avez répondu déjà beaucoup de
critiques je vais me poser des questions
simples qu'on se pose encore des trois
questions un travail en siège social
vous avez un siège social en plus d'une
boîte postale en bois d'une boîte
postale vous avez un siège social bien
sûr un bon est ce que c'est vrai vous
avez je reviens sur d'autres en question
de la vie privée est ce que c'est vrai
que vous avez exclus des militants parce
qu'il s'était marié vrai faux non non
jamais je me jeanne est donc on a le
droit de se marier vous n'avez jamais
demander à quelqu'un de partir du labo
l'organisation sommer sont mariés bon
alors vous dites quand même j'aurais je
voudrais quand même répondre à certaines
choses là françois koch ils précisent
pas puisque c'est un informateur qu'il a
été condamné deux fois pour diffamation
1 pour mme avoir diffamé bon alors j'en
veux à la presse mais il ya des fois des
raisons d'en vouloir à la presse
alors il a été condamné d'abord et puis
en appel bon vous dites dans un document
interne quand même que
lutte ouvrière c'est pas une
organisation pec nous devons construire
mais une organisation de crise une
organisation de combat c'est vrai que ça
peut sembler bizarre qu'on dit ça
aujourd'hui en 2003 quoi on est dans une
nouvelle aventure et qu'elles sont assez
dure c'est ça que je veux dire qu'aucune
situation on est aujourd'hui comment le
capitaliste en train de réduire des
millions de gens y compris dans ce pays
à la misère à la pauvreté à perdre son
travail combien de gens n'ont pas de
logement comment sont traités les
sans-papiers encore hier qui s'en fait
exclure du gymnase japy et cetera vous
croyez qu'à part des raisons de combat
dead avoir une organisation qui
défendent les plus pense qu'ils
défendent les travailleurs contre
l'exploitation capitaliste mais jamais
ça a été autant d'actualité
qu'aujourd'hui mais jean-luc mélenchon
est ce que je t'ouvre hier au fond le
monopole j'allais dire la défense de ce
type de combat où est-ce qu'on peut
défendre les travailleurs d'une autre
façon ils font bien comme ils veulent un
mois c'est pas sur ce terrain là que je
défendrai mais c'est vraiment une
occasion assez assez hors du commun que
de pouvoir échanger avec vous sur le
fond de la politique parce que on vous
reproche qu'on veut mais vous méritez
aussi le respect des millions de gens
qui votent pour vous à partir de là vous
avez une responsabilité et s'alarment
plus hardis par exemple vous parliez de
l'union libre apparemment c'est un idéal
philosophie je vous comprends mais qui a
fait le pas que j'ai dit que j'étais
pour qu'il a fait nous nous le
réformiste est alors en plus moi alors
plus le premier à avoir déposé le texte
mais vous voyez donc cette action de
réforme
je trouve que vous la méprise et d'une
façon qui est incompréhensible je vais
vous donner un exemple avant même qu'on
soit arrivé au deuxième tour dire on n'y
est pas arrivé à arles est donc comme ça
pour m s'est pas posée avant même qu'on
y soit arrivée vous aviez annoncé que
vous n'hésiteriez par l'ida de gauche
arrivé en tête donc ça veut dire pour
vous c'est pareil chirales j'ose pas la
droite la gauche est tous pareils il ya
vous qui avez raison et pas nous je
voudrais pour l'ex noir g7 6 janvier
prochain ça me scie shadow s'il n'y
avait pas eu tous les plans de
suppressions d'emplois qui a eu son
gouvernement jospin pour lequel le
gouvernement jospin n'a pouvoir lever le
petit doigt
aurait nécessairement différent je pense
que jospin aurait gagné vous dites c'est
tout organisme
travailleurs de moulinex de danone ou
d'ailleurs vous osez dire c'est ne rien
vous avez même pas tiré la leçon de
pourquoi les élections étaient perdus
par lionel jospin justement vous pouvez
pas demander à socialiste des
trotskistes comme vous nous sommes
socialistes nous avons donc une autre
manière d'approcher la réalité sociale
que vous vous on respecte votre droit à
voir votre idée respecter le nôtre est
ce que pour pouvoir bénéficier de votre
appui c'est ce que c'est un rapport de
force quand même dans une entreprise on
fait pas le tri ou demande pacha de gaz
qui prend la tête on lui demande d'aller
et ben là c'est pareil quand vous êtes
devant un deuxième tour pourquoi est-ce
que vous décidez que ceux qui ne pensent
pas comme vous parce qu'ils pensent pas
comme vous parce que c'est nous les
socialistes hop on est pareil que la
droite
politique qu'ils ont regardé le pen
alors jean dujardin ont touché dès le
pen qui sépare et verts s'étaient pas
vous vous ne l'acceptez passagers du
ministre alors jaloux rivés vers le
mondial lorsque j'ai bien entendu ce que
vient de dire avec la quille mais moi je
suis élu de la seine maritime
vous avez deux élus au conseil régional
la seine maritime
lorsque nous faisons que lorsque nous
proposons des mesures et je vous en
donne des exemples s'agit pas de
licenciements il s'agit pas de fermeture
de site lorsqu'un lorsque par exemple
lorsque nous décidons parce qu'en effet
c'est un département qu'elle a besoin
de rendre gratuit l'attribution des
livres scolaires jusqu'à la terminale
qui votent recontre avec l'extrême
droite vos deux délégués et comment
pouvez-vous justifier ça lorsque nous
décidons parce que nous avons beaucoup
de chômeurs doivent de subventionner de
subventionner les transports des
chômeurs pour qu'ils puissent d'un côté
à l'autre du département aller chercher
du travail qui votre compte avec
l'extrême droite vos deux élus et je
prends ce vrai mais comme ça
m'étonnerait que mais carla à leur cause
ce
que joueur cité nous parlons de noël de
mon fils et je veux dire que nous
venions qu'on lorsque ça va aux écoles
non non non non non c'est parce que je
vais le drapeau si c'est le cas oui et
je tai chi souviendrez scénario
astucieux
c'est une politique
du tout ou rien voilà si on ne peut pas
tout changer il ne faut rien changer et
ça c'est une politique conservatrice et
réactionnaire et je pèse mes mots et
c'est moi je suis là montrer par ce que
j'ai vu faire en seine maritime je
laissais exemple nous protéger la maison
là on pourrait donner le même exemple
sur la taxe tobin vous avez voté contre
8 août a fait ou prenez exemple sur le
barrage à le pen elle avait été proposée
avait alors trois est dévolu sur l'air
de la phrase alors vous êtes des radis
d'hiver et vous êtes des conservateurs
de la réalité et vous verrez qu'elle
millions mais moi je suis un réformiste
je suis fier de ce que nous avons fait
nous avons fait la couverture médicale
universelle que ce gouvernement nous
avons fait là pas que ce gouvernement
prend nous avons fait tout un ensemble
de réformes que ce gouvernement de
droite détricote celle ci c'était bonnet
blanc et blanc bonnet pourquoi il veut
être le contraire de ce qu'on prenne
quelques frictions d'électeurs se sont
détournés de vous c'est nous qui avons
détourné c'est vous quand même c'est
vous par votre politique
alors est-ce qu'ils vont revenir et
critique pas je veux tu être
descendu et partial en trente ans il est
arrivé à
64 ans le tuv rien et et françois sont
pas trop pouvez pas nous dire ah vous
avez perdu des lecteurs vous 64 ans
j'ai voiture est non mais non même des
gens envers l'être la pression tout au
plus alors je n'ai pas produit hier sur
le carreau pendant cinq ans vous savez
est-ce que vous avez vu et tout ça que
vous avez perdu laisse vous et moi je
vous considère comme un peu moins
aujourd'hui on les a gagnés c'est pour
ça se comprend pas pourquoi pourquoi
quand il faut donner le coup de collier
vous n'êtes pas là où ils partent ils
nous attaquent des déclarations
abstraite vous nous renvoyez tous
dos-à-dos par exemple le fait qu'ils
sont des
consultants vous avez c'est en
résistance des jeux et la joue surtout à
girac chacun doit rester à la maison je
fais la différence était pas la peine de
voter chirac pour que le pen passe pas
mais vous qu'elle savait vous et aplatit
là dessus mais attends qu est ce que
vous étiez trop content de pas avoir de
ses nouvelles par ce que je peux dire
qu'elle n'a pas qu'ils étaient contents
alors soit le sujet quand bernard siens
c'est une autre personne n'avait dit
effectivement qu'il fallait faire
barrage à jean marie le pen que si tu
m'avais près la même attitude que vous
savez combien risque en éprouvait et
prouve est battu rien qu'avec les vrais
de la droite non il n'avait pas besoin
de mes fils il avait plu avait fait 35
ou 40 % catastrophe est ce que ce
serait si tu ne sais pas mais ça le
rapport
qui sert des boissons et à 35% c'est pas
pareil c'est pour vous c'est pareil si
on voyait les déchirer big chirac avait
pourtant ces schémas 4 82% 19% tout le
monde le sait et ne voulaient c'est
qu'on
profite de ses 82 pourtant el rapha bat
on profite sarkozy en profite et ses
cibles
alors maintenant c'est simple vous avez
hérité et que vous avez de coller au
peuple de gauche je ne sais pas si c'est
comme ça les congrès trotskisme et ça
doit être quelque chose
pour présenter les produits c'est eux
nous nous sommes des socialistes elle
été respectée j'étais trop triste et
j'ai deux et je me tirerais jamais un
mot pour en dire du mal ça plus j'en
fais un doute je retiens les trotskistes
et eux ils sont organisés et je sais pas
comment ça se passe dans leur corps et
ça m'étonnerait qu'on s'engueule autant
qu'on arrête de faire alors si c'est
pascal
20e il a une petite question à reléguer
quand même est ce que pensait pas que
oui il ya une incompréhension à l'égard
de ce vote du second tour de votre
position pour disque dur ça va dépendre
du milieu social je peux vous dire que
on peut ne pas nous croire parce qu'on a
décidé qu'arlette laguiller c'était fini
à cause du vote moi j'ai été soutenir
les travailleurs 2d où les travailleurs
d'as et et croyez moi combien sont venus
me dire que nous avions eu raison de
pâtes noté chirac quand on voit la
politique de chirac et de raffarin quand
on voit les mesures sécuritaires de
sarkozy aujourd'hui en temps quand on
voit tout ça croyez moi et puis combien
m'ont dit je regrette de l'avoir fait
vous ne croyez pas méchant il ya dans
les milieux sociaux qui sont peut-être
pas ce que vous serez tenté notamment on
est tous antérieur avec compris donc
vous laissez tomber les murs alors le
conseil ne laisse pas tomber justement
laisse pas tomber à l'axé ville ouvrière
tout le monde s'en fout c'est par le
travail et harry peuvent crever parce
que vous avez vous verrez du sens à ces
états ne pas voir
tout le monde s'en fout - sûrement fut
pas moi non plus je me fous pas et aucun
de mes camarades s'en fout et c'est le
sens de l'engagement
mon but si ce qui est engagée
c'est donc voila quand on est socialiste
pour eux on y est une espèce de bête à
abattre qu'on ne peut même pas écouté
vos montres et l'ennemi principal quand
on est socialiste pour eux on est
l'ennemi principal est qu'ils m'ont
fait partie à vous savez vous qui avez
une culture indoor c'est quand même
terrifiant avoir ça vous me rappelez
vous savez quoi il ya peu de gens qui
vont suivre mais c'est les communistes
des années 30 en allemagne parce qu ils
ont fait exactement ce que vous faites
il montrait du doigt les socialistes en
disant c'est le frère jumeau du fascisme
jusqu'à ce qu'ils claire fait le pouvoir
et vous vous faites pareil parce que
vous dites que nous sommes les frères
lui avait délivré un cours celle ci si
vous
les travailleurs y méritent qu'on les
éduque et qu'on leur ait un jeu de la
vérité il s'avance et elle a crié je
dois street a été fort depuis le début
depuis le début de l'émission
les deux socialistes à ma droite donne
beaucoup de voix pour une raison mais
ces
essais les parents je disais donc que
les deux socialistes qui sont à ma
droite et pas uniquement géographique
donne beaucoup de voix et s'énerve
beaucoup pour une raison qu'on n'aborde
pas mais je crois beaucoup de gens qui
sont ici ou que nous regardons envie
qu'on pose cette question c'est parce
que arlette laguiller et olivier
besancenot c'est à dire lutte ouvrière
est là elle faire on fait 3 millions de
voix aux présidentielles ont atteint
près de 10% et que ça c'est l'événement
politique de l'année alors ça existe ça
explique peut-être l'excitation de mes
voisins et à son
nom mais je te demande pas d'avoir une
tête d'enterrement même si il ya eu en
partie l'enterrement de la gauche
traditionnelle aux dernières élections
mais je crois que ce qui intéresse les
gens aujourd'hui parce qu autant être
franc cinquante ans qui
s'est pas fondamentalement ça vous fait
même si c'est par négligeable de savoir
comment fonctionne lutte ouvrière moi
j'ai beaucoup de désaccords avec eux
cinoche la lutte ouvrière c'est de
savoir pourquoi aujourd'hui il ya deux
organisations qui se réclament de
l'extrême gauche qui ensemble ont fait
un score absolument historique et qui à
mon avis va se prolonger parce qu'il ya
une place politique pour ça or ces deux
organisations d'extrême gauche sont
occasionnellement ensemble aux élections
arlette et moi on s'est retrouvés sur la
même liste aux européennes et il ya eu
trois camarades de lutte ouvrière 2 de
la ligue qui ont été élus mais il faut
bien le reconnaître la presse l'a dit et
c'est vrai jusqu'à présent on n'arrive
pas à aller beaucoup plus loin que de
temps en temps encore des accords
électoraux moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
justement qu'on discute alors peut-être
vous allez vous trouver un peu loin là
mais comme il serait
sans doute finance quels sont les points
d'accord du sommet entre lutte ouvrière
et la ligue et qu'elles sont aussi parce
qu'il y en a bien sûr des poèmes d abord
salon doit céder
lancement des élections 7 500 cas où là
c'est souvent dans la rue en ce moment
les uns derrière les autres pas avec une
banderole commune alors mais karl était
morose et certains nombres de lutte et
pas des cibles potentielles et de
refaire un bout de chemin en france
février est ce que c'est possible est ce
que c'est possible de refaire un bout de
chemin ensemble avec la ligue communiste
oui il est ouvrière et tous les deux
mais pourquoi si vous parlez d'une
fusion des organisations les plus
question de ça actuellement et on croit
que personne ne demande n'y a ni
direction de lutte ouvrière ni à la
direction de la lcr si vous parler
d'accords électoraux futur et puis c'est
d'abord les élections c'est l'année
prochaine c'est possible c'est possible
si on est capable de faire un accord
politique c'est sur la base d'un accord
politique alors réussir at on pas à
faire cet accord politique j'en sais
rien aujourd'hui donc tout ça on verra
c'est dans les mois qui vont venir que
on aura ces discussions entre les deux
organisations mais pour le moment on
n'en est rien il vous savez c'est pas
sûr que je sais pas il y aurait une
candidature commune l'aiguillé
besancenot n'auraient pas leur place est
avec moi
donnez moi mais en se présentant
séparément parce que il ya des gens qui
votent pour lots mais qui veulent pas
pour la ligue et qu'il serait donc tout
ça je m'en impliqué cela il a été
diabolique alain krivine de lancer aux
livres besancenot contre vous non c'est
vrai que vous avez pardonnez moi je suis
pas désagréable mais ça fait vieillir un
peu les candidatures de léopard oui mais
c'est les idées qu'ils vieillissent peau
vous savez c'est alors là je crois
qu'avec la lcr heureusement n'a pas ce
genre de débat et ce qui vaut mieux un
jeune qu'un pluvieux pour new rave est
très différent ce tournoi je comprends
pas vous êtes tous trotskiste il ya eu
aussi une troisième famille
transférant lyon font peur grande
tendance du ps
avec vite on ne fait pas un grand parti
trotskiste ça nous évitera de voir ce
ridicule à tous trois candidats stration
c'est à dire exceptionnelle c'est un
combat était parti trotskiste vous êtes
de la même famille des vues de leurs
aînés à rien
et on annonce a propulsé de ça pas
besoin d'états lors d'un congrès comme
le t'ouvrir qu'on nous explique t il je
tenais différence entre 02 2011 et du
rangement des différences on sait qu'on
n'a pas le temps pourquoi vraie sortie
si t'es pas au mouvement qui
mondialisation pourquoi on vous voit pas
dans les grandes manifestations
antimondialisation alors qu'on voit
l'organisation de l'ain krivine est ce
que ça vous semble pas une lutte
importante intéressante où vous aimez un
ferrailleur
nous
pensons que les gens qui n'y est en
particulier la jeunesse qui se battent
dans cette lutte eh bien il est tout à
fait respectable
maintenant nous pensons qu'il y à
d'autres luttes à mener plus urgentes
plus importante plus difficile peut-être
et que nous bat nous sommes aussi une
petite organisation et nous
nous réservons comment dire le travail
que nous on la lutte que nous menons
ainsi que je l'expliqué dans ce bouquin
parce que si nous ne faisons pas
personne ne le fera allons donc nous
vous laisser la lutte anti modélisation
et autres et qu'on termine avec thierry
jonquet il a travaillé le laisse pas la
lutte anticapitaliste mais réimplanter
les idées communistes révolutionnaires
dans les andes dans les entreprises en
particulier dans un tas de milieux
sociaux ça demande un bien d'autres
investissements et on peut pas
franchement aller se balader sur tout et
dans toutes les villes du monde c'est
sympa on n'allait pas pour tous à
l'aigre avec avec jean luc mélenchon ça
vous intéresse pas pour toi l'est non
trop de gens qui vont pour pour se
montrer mais qu'on pas du tout envie de
changer la société de renverser ok mais
pourquoi parce que vous avez décidé
comme ça à l'extérieur ce qu'ils
écrivent on lit ce qu'ils disent alors
qu'il
embauche nom avait aussi salué des rsa
ce que niasse qui
se sont d'accord mais moi je ce qu'ils
font c'est leur problème je comprends
que ça intéresse du monde mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est il ya 6 millions
comme l'a dit krivine c'est très juste
six millions de personnes qui votent
pour eux moi je les respecte ces gens là
vous aussi d'ailleurs je vous respecte
tout pourquoi vous voulez
y aller ou pas par exemple ceux qui
votent front national est présent
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi ne fait pas
cet effort d'essayer d'écouter les
autres pour voir à quel moment on peut
mettre ensemble des forces pour laisser
les gens ajoute des pressions pour m
pourquoi vous pouvez pas mettre
maintenant la grêle concept pas dans là
je voudrais dans les grèves c'est pas
pareil je sais car
je réponds en une fois permettra y
compris de voir les désaccords les
accords avec lutte ouvrière ouais moi je
crois qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya deux
domaines qui sont complémentaires et pas
les mêmes il ya un domaine aujourd'hui
qui est de résister aux attaques
frontales de rafah un brin contre le
mouvement social dans cette résistance
nous à la ligue on est pour l'unité la
plus large de tous ceux et toutes celles
qui sont prêts à descendre dans la rue
ou à faire grève aujourd'hui une seconde
je
vous dis que là ça y est gentil on
comprend par les différentes là dessus
je suis pas passion il ya un accord sur
les mots doivent s'asseoir sur les
retraites la sécurité sociale les
licenciements les sans-papiers quelle
qu'ait été la politique par ailleurs et
à mon avis je suis pas prêt de l'oublier
mais si aujourd'hui on arrive à se
mettre d'accord contre la politique de
rafah je suis pour l'unité sans
exclusive je dis bien sans exclusif
quelques été l'attitude des uns et des
autres par rapport au gouvernement
maintenant il ya une deuxième tâche et
ça moi je suis pas prêt à le faire ni
avec vous ni avec les dirigeants du pcc
aujourd'hui c'est répondre justement à
ce nouveau mouvement social s'est donné
une réponse politique une alternative
politique vous avez je termine des
millions de gens qui ne se reconnaissent
plus dans la gauche traditionnelle vu ce
que vous avez fait au gouvernement jeudi
qui a placé aujourd'hui pour construire
un grand parti des travailleurs le
bieler nommé par jean luc mélenchon le
mélange ça sera pas parti trotskiste en
tout cas c'est mon point de vue ça doit
être un parti qui rassemble toutes les
forces authentiquement anticapitaliste
qui tirait comptes et bilans celui de la
politique et qui soit à faire faire la
même chose quand elle joue la main avec
norbert marseille en deux secondes
juste mettre un bémol ya un gros
problème aujourd'hui quel problème des
retraites et moi je suis prête à me
battre avec tous ceux qui veulent se
battre là dessus mais à condition que
les choses soient claires complet de
l'abrogation des mesures balladur qui
ont ramené de 37 ans et demi à 40 ans
dans le privé le nombre de cotisations
qu'on défende les 37 ans et demi et
qu'on arrête de mentir parce que comment
voulez vous qu'on croit des soi disant
experts incapable de prévoir quelle va
être la croissance demain et qu'il nous
explique que dans 20 ans dans 40 ans on
pourra pas payer les retraites alors
vous savez en 1905 par exemple est ce
qu'on aurait pu dire ce qui se serait
passé en 1945 on peut prévoir 40 ans
avant qu est vrai qu'elle va être la
situation aujourd'hui il ya de l'argent
encore dans les caisses de retraite et
puis il ya d'énormes profits qui sont
faites par de grandes entreprises
prenons là dessus mais maintenant la
retraite des travailleurs à une retraite
décente par les parties alors petit
cadeau pour terminer je vous propose
d'écouter quelqu'un dans lequel
bah les uns et les autres vous allez
vous reconnaitre voilà petit sonore
certains ont au moins fait
un don ou
dvd le métro est mort est bénigne selon
robert barcia je termine avec vous quand
même parce que sinon le débat raconter
toute la nuit avec la gauche vous vous
irez jusqu'au bout vous ne changerez
jamais et
pas question pana iota quand des stands
et je ne changerai jamais j'en sais rien
mais je pour le moment j'ai pas
l'intention de changer voilà quant à
changer jamais
personne ne peut dire fontaine je ne
boirai pas de ton nous mais attention
messieurs bardés bon je dis attention
mais si mélenchon est le messie changea
alors merci à tous et
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette émission merci à vous de l'avoir
interpellé donc un véritable histoire de
lutte ouvrière les entretiens avec
christophe bourseiller c'est donc chez
denoël nous allons donc parler
maintenant de la manière dont la france
peut au nom résister ou s'opposer aux
états unis
récit sans doute d'affrontements
petite passe d'armes notamment verbale
entre la france et les états unis donc
rappelle avec pascal golomer
c'est la dernière passe d'armes en date
samedi à munich donald rumsfeld le
ministre de la défense américain
s'adresse directement au responsable
française et allègue
la france et l'allemagne s'isoleront eux
mêmes plutôt que d'isoler les états in a
row
la réponse allemande ne tarde pas et
c'est michèle alliot marie qui se
chargent de la réplique française est
rallié
c'est savoir se consulter
pour trouver un consensus
ça n'est pas de dire
mon idée est forcément la bonne et tous
ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord avec moi
doivent être écartées ou exclue et c'est
ainsi depuis des mois
[Musique]